[Music]
your love interest community is our good
pal very nice guy and I'm right you
recently tweeted a picture of both of
you is this correct that many photos of
the two of us I have not seen this you
compared what you compared to parts of
yourselves yes yes
well we compared what we compared Joel's
butt crack specifically and my cleavage
obviously so you took pictures of both
and you see we did very close pictures
of both and then we tweeted them to see
if people could tell the difference I
feel like it should be said that we
should reference something that
everybody knows which is that joel has
an incredibly high butt crack I didn't
know that another guy a while I didn't
know that is this something everybody
knows I there's not one day I go to work
without seeing Joel's
butt crack it's that high up pants
cannot cover it he's a tall man leaving
your saying it goes up Jane between his
shoulder blades well let's take a look
at this I think we have a picture of
both of your yeah I don't know what to
be attracted to here we tweeted it and
people felt the same way we got a lot of
mixed responses and it was difficult for
many to guess okay
which I took as a compliment because
joel has such a perky tush so what the
compliment is for you or for him
for me because I was happy that people
thought that my boobs looked like his
perky but why is kicking your ass
Wow your your boobs sure look like bucks
Oh Ricky buddy the list of terrible
compliments women get